unsere follower auf instagram haben uns
viele fragen zur amerikanischen wahl
gestellt und wir wollen jetzt einige
beantworten was passiert wenn trump eine
niederlage nicht akzeptieren sollte es
ist natürlich spekulation aber trump hat
tatsächlich gesagt dass er das ergebnis
nur akzeptiert wenn er der sieger ist
und er hat bewaffnete leute aufgefordert
in wahllokalen nach dem rechten zu sehen
es kann also schon sein dass er das
ergebnis nicht akzeptieren möchte ob er
damit durchkommt das hängt glaube ich
sehr viele davon ab was die republikaner
tun glauben andere republikaner sie
haben auch etwas zu gewinnen wenn man
möglichst viele briefwahlstimmen als
illegitim ansicht und so versucht doch
noch einen sieg zu haben
oder wollen sie anfangen das zu tun was
sie eines tages sowieso tun müssen und
zu sagen wir müssen jetzt auf distanz
gehen von donald trump denn er hat
verloren davon wird es abhängen denn
ganz alleine wird er diesen kampf nicht
gewinnen können was auch immer passiert
am zwanzigsten januar um 12 uhr beginnt
die amtszeit des nächsten präsidenten
wenn trump sich dann einfach weigert den
gewählten präsidenten platz zu machen
dann wird der secret service ihn aus dem
weißen haus eskortieren
warum wird jeder fehler von trump
gnadenlos überhöht das ist ein vorwurf
den wir journalisten oft hören und es
ist tatsächlich nicht ganz leicht einen
präsidenten wie donald trump zu covern
stellen sie sich mal vor sie sind selbst
reporter und es ist der tag an dem
donald trump sagt ich möchte grünland
kaufen was machen sie da raus sie können
sagen das ist eine posse passiert
sowieso nicht richtig nicht drüber oder
sie können sagen was für eine
unverschämtheit
eine teilautonome insel die nicht zum
verkauf steht will der amerikanische
präsident einfach kaufen das mutterland
dänemark ist ein nato-partner ein großer
frauen sie machen eine große geschichte
daraus songs zu covern heißt ständig
solche abwägungen zu treffen aber am
ende ist dies ein präsident der
rechtsradikale unterstützt hat der
rassismus verbreitet der die axt an die
demokratie legt dem brutale despoten
wichtiger sind als seine bündnispartner
und bei so einem präsidenten kein
journalistischer ausgewogenheit nicht
bedeuten dass man genauso viele fehler
bei ihm wie bei seinen konkurrenten oder
wie bei seinem vorgänger obama findet
trump ist ein zerstörer er feiert sich
als zerstörer und unser job ist es das
zu berichten
und niemand wäre trauriger als donald
trump wenn wir es nicht hätten
warum glauben so viele leute alles was
trump sagt kurze antwort würde ich sagen
weil sie es wollen längere antwort weil
die amerikaner in verschiedenen
universen leben geradezu in
verschiedenen realitäten die medien sind
so gestalten dass man nicht nur
verschiedene versionen desselben
sachverhalts hört sondern oft noch nicht
mal denselben inhalt wird wenn man cnn
guckt oder fox news zum beispiel auf der
rechten
die washington post hat schon im sommer
festgestellt dass trump als präsident
20.000 unwahre oder irreführende
behauptungen aufgestellt hat 2016 gegen
hillary clinton ist trotzdem eher als
die ehrliche haut wahrgenommen worden
das lag daran dass hillary clinton
bekannt dafür war immer alles ganz genau
auf die goldwaage zu legen nichts zu
sagen was sie mich vorher mit ihren
beratern überlegt hatte und das kam den
leuten verlogen vor und nicht der
tatsächlich viele lügen verbreiten der
donald trump dieses jahr ist das ein
bisschen anders weil joe biden selbst
zum flunkern neigt und nicht ganz so
geschnitten redet ganz viele install
user haben uns gefragt was hat beiden
eigentlich vor wenn er präsident wird
kurz gesagt könnte man sagen vor allem
will er sehr viel geld ausgeben und das
ist eigentlich ungewöhnlich denn als
senator gehörte beiden immer zu denen
die davor gewarnt haben zu viele neue
schulden zu machen
aber jetzt gibt es die korona krise das
kostet geld dagegen vorzugehen beiden
möchte zum beispiel hunderttausend leute
rekrutieren und kontakte nach zu
verfolgen
vor allem kostet es geld aus dieser
wirtschaftskrise herauszukommen und den
unternehmern die kurz vor der pleite
stehenden aufzuhelfen all das will
beiden tun er will auch geld ausgeben
für eine ökologische transformation zur
klimaneutralität allerdings will er
nicht das fracking verbieten wohl aber
dem pariser klimaschutzabkommen
möglichst bald wieder beitreten
außerdem hat beiden versprochen schon in
seinen ersten 100 tagen etwas gegen
rassismus und polizeigewalt zu tun zum
beispiel durch die schaffung eines neuen
gremiums dass polizisten im ganzen land
auf die finger schauen soll und vorfälle
aufklären soll
auch nach dem wahltag wird es unheimlich
spannend weitergehen buy.at bleiben sie
immer gut informiert